- So Al, your new book, I love the title.
Anybody that knows me that sees your book,
buys your book, reads your
book is going to laugh
because literally the
thing said most to me
in my life, in my career is
the title of your book, "You
Look So Much Better in Person."
I honestly thought it was just me.
Every time I run into people, they're like
"You look so much better in person."
I'm like, "Thank you since
85% of my life is on camera."
(laughter)
And they say that to you all the time?
- Yeah, every day, yeah
I go out and shake hands
at the Plaza obviously pre-pandemic
and invariably one person,
at least one person will say,
"Oh my gosh, you look so
much better in person."
- Every time.
- And I know they mean it as a compliment
- Absolutely.
- so I don't want to embarrass them.
To your point, I make my living on TV.
- That's what I say!
- So, that I look better
here just means that
I'm scaring small children on television.
- Yeah, like what does that mean?
And they're always like, "You're
shorter and you're smaller,
"you're more petite"
and I'm just like, "Do
I look like an Amazon?"
Or they say that at concerts.
They'll come backstage
after a concert and be like
"Oh my god, you sound better in person."
I'm like "Great because most of it's not
in person, so solid."
It's amazing.